hello welcome to data science for
everyone even if you're scared of math
or don't know how to program a computer
you've never even heard of data science
this presentation is still for you what
I'm gonna talk about is a high-level
description of how I do data science
other people will give you different
answers but hopefully this will get you
started the very first step is it get
data and if you have data get more data
so when I say data
I mean numbers and names that's data
that's numerical and categorical what I
mean by that
numbers are things that are amounts or
counts something that can be measured in
extent money pixel brightness sound
intensity where names or categorical
variables are things like type of dog or
a variety of hot drink or the ID the
identification of an aircraft or the
model number of a droid or an ice cream
flavor or something like the contents of
a text it's a name if you change it a
little bit it could become a completely
different name if you change a number by
a little bit it's still pretty close to
the original number now to confuse this
issue there are names that look like
numbers a phone number if you change it
by just one points to an entirely
different person and that person's not
necessarily closer than if you change it
by a thousand or ten thousand a phone
number is a name that looks like a
number similarly a zip code if you
change it by just one or two you might
find a place that's relatively close
geographically but it will still be a
completely different place
and it could be the changing a zip code
by a thousand might produce another zip
code that's right next to the original
one again identification numbers
double-oh-seven there's lots of types of
identification numbers serial numbers
credit card numbers social security
numbers you change any one of those by
ten or by a thousand or by a million
either way they'll point to something
complete completely different and to
further confuse the issue there are
numbers that look like names ordinals
for instance and names that can be
turned into numbers so these are names
that have a distinct order like first
second third and it helps if the
difference between each of these is
similar small medium large there's a
distinct order and a medium is about as
much bigger than a small as a large is
than a medium left middle right you need
to go time zones train stops anything
that has an order can be turned into a
number and interpreted by a machine
learning algorithm the process of
measuring and collecting and storing and
searching and moving and transforming
data names and numbers is a special bit
of work special discipline to itself
Asher has a lot of tools to do this and
we're gonna talk about him a lot during
this conference I encourage you to keep
an eye out for them and learn as much as
you can we won't talk about them in this
presentation here we'll stick to the
fundamental conceptual notions of data
science the things that you will try to
do with all of these tools I would also
like to point you to the Cortana
analytics process you see these five
steps below here these are similar to
the steps that I'm going to talk about
today they place special
offices on the tools that you use and
give specific instructions on how to use
those tools to get these results there
our next step so after this presentation
go and check that out to further your
education after you have data the next
thing you need to do is ask a sharp
question and the thing you're looking
for is is your target in the data
they'll explain what I mean by that to
start with if you have a vague question
it doesn't have to be answered with the
name or a number you can imagine that
there's a genie in a lamp and it emerges
from the lamp and it will answer any
question you ask it truthfully but it's
a mischievous Genie and it will ask
answer as unhelpfully as it can so if
you ask it a vague question like how can
I increase my profits you may get an
answer like work harder true as far as
it goes but it's not specific enough to
be helpful whereas if you ask it a sharp
question that has to be answered with
the name or a number such as how many
times will the feature that I built get
used by a new user
the genie can't help that give you the
correct numerical answer to that
question there's no wiggle room that's
the type of question you want to ask
your data you need to make sure that
your data includes your target your
target is an example of answers to your
question that came in the past so if
your question is what will my stock
price be next week your target is a
history of stock prices so you can
gather sales information by region
information on your competitors project
products you can gather information
about your users and how long they've
been around and external information
about markets
none of that will do you any good in
answering your question until you also
have a history of your stock price so
that you can line it up with those and
find the patterns if you don't have your
target in the data go get more data if
you do put your data in a table this is
not quite as trivial as it sounds it has
to go in your table so that there's one
target value per row one instance of
your target variable for each row in
this case with our stock price history
we recorded the stock price at the close
every day so we have one row per day now
a lot of the data that we would like to
include doesn't naturally occur once per
day for instance total users the way
we've stored this data is user name and
date joined a long list in order to get
total users we have to aggregate sum
over that list this is a common method
to get things to line up it rows another
way the complement to this is to
distribute there are some quantities
like last month's sales or new users
last month that are going to be the same
for this entire month last month is
still the same month that it was and so
that number is going to be constant so
in order to line it up one per row we
distribute it and copy it across all of
the relevant rows another thing we find
ourselves doing quite often is computing
so for instance days sends press release
or days since product release in this
case our data may be stored as a date
and the name of the press release in
order to find the days since the press
we have to take the date of the last
press release and today's date and
subtract them do a little calculation
another thing we may have to do is
simply measure if we need something that
we didn't create ourselves we may have
to go out and gather that data maybe
someone else collected it for us and we
can get it from them or maybe we have to
get it from scratch but something like
the average Dow Jones Industrial Average
for each day another thing we can do is
estimate some times at the time we
create our table we don't have the most
recent data and we can't calculate or
distribute or aggregate to get the
number so we may have to fudge it make
some educated guesses if we know if we
have a basis for making a guess that's
better than leaving it blank
we've still added some information but
when all else fails we can leave blanks
we don't want to leave too many because
the more we leave the trickier it gets
to do quality data science but there are
ways to handle it so after the data is
in a table with one row per instance of
the target the next step is to check for
quality we want to make sure the data is
acceptable to use so here's a table we
can see going through the columns the
very last row is our target variable
where is a cape this is a bunch of data
on different superheroes and
supervillains and we want to be able to
predict in the future given a new
superhero or super villain whether or
not they wear a cape based on everything
else we know about them now when you go
to survey data for quality I don't know
of any shortcuts to the process of
walking through the data what this means
is you go to the first column you look
at the title you
think about what it means if it's not
clear you look up what it means if it's
not written down you talk to the person
who created it and find out what it
means if you still don't know you make a
guess of what it means with that in mind
you visually scroll through the data for
large datasets you won't be able to go
through the whole dataset so you can
look at aggregations you can look at the
unique values you can look at histograms
of how much of each value occur and make
sure that it makes sense make sure that
you don't see anything that makes you
[ __ ] your head and squint and think does
that look right because if you do then
it probably means there's an error in
the data and it may need correction or
clarification this is almost always the
case in real data so we'll go through
this data first we look at the ID column
we scan through that and it becomes
pretty clear this is just a unique
numerical identifier for each row very
common in databases we look at the next
column first name those look like all
fine first names they're all
alphabetical they're all capitalized
they seem formatted well same with the
last names all very plausible no red
flags when we get to birth year we
assume this is the year when each of
these individuals was born but some of
these quantities don't look like years
at all some of them have stray
punctuation peter parker's year
looks like someone retyped the number
one several times some have quotes if
you look down at Thor 2287 BC that's a
perfectly valid year but by appending BC
on there it becomes non numerical and
the machine learning algorithm doesn't
know how what to do with it in order to
clean this up we need to make sure these
are all format
the same way after we go through and fix
them this is what it looks like we even
took the 20 287 BC and just turned it
into negative 22 87 so that it could
very easily be interpreted by our
algorithm next we look at the height
this is nice easy to interpret uniformly
formatted the difficulty here is we know
that height is numerical we know that 6
1 is much closer to 6 2 than it is to 5
1 that's not represented when these
things are in strings with symbols the
foot and inch tick marks so we need to
change them to a numerical form once we
change them to inches now they're
naturally interpretable by the algorithm
we look at the birthplace and again
these all look like very reasonably
formatted names it looks like some
cleanup has occurred already on these
this column we do have an unknown in
there but that's reasonable enough um
this column identity is secret so this
looks like a yes or no does this person
have a secret identity so in the case of
Bruce Wayne yes in the case of Ororo
Munroe not applicable it's not totally
clear what that means and we look down
at victor von doom missing again it's
not totally obvious what that means
Janet Van Dyne nothing at all so there's
some ambiguity in the data in order to
use it to its best effect we need to
figure out what is intended here and
some in some cases make some guesses or
do a little bit of research talk to who
recorded it or if they've left the
company talked to someone who heard
something about who recorded it and make
a guess after doing that we end up with
a nice every row is why or
and uniform representation two levels
very easily interpretable by an
algorithm next column can fly again it
appears that this column is an indicator
of whether an individual can fly but it
looks like whoever entered this was
using different standards some are
numerical a 3 & a 9 and a 12 and a 1 and
it's clear based on the fact that Clark
Kent is a 12 and Bruce Wayne is a 3 that
high numbers mean a good flier we have
notes jet presumably can fly but in a
jet Lev which we do some research and
find it's short for levitate we have
some no not a clue
applicable blank so again it takes some
interpretation when we first look at
this and we look at all of the unique
values then we plot a histogram of how
many times each occurs it's clear that
there's a lot of noise and a lot of
different standards after we go through
and clean it up it becomes very simple
yes-no in some cases this is
oversimplification but it helps the
machine learning algorithm to interpret
it well again alignment another case
lots of different things lots of
different ways to say the same things in
some cases do we go through we look at
what it means and we unify it and in
this case we end up with three levels
mostly good some bad
and one neutral Selina Kyle is tough to
categorize it's okay to have more than
two categories it's okay to have more
than ten categories as long as the
representation is uniform and everything
that's intended to be the same is called
the same we finally get to wear the Cape
we treat the target variable just like
any other look through
think about what it means and unify it
now we have a nice clean rectangular non
empty uniform representation this data
is ready to start processing in an
algorithm so the next step
transform features and are the new
features predictive and I'll talk about
what that means sometimes the data that
you get needs a little bit of massaging
before it can help you answer your
question this is called feature
engineering that's just a fancy word for
taking the features that you already
have and doing something to them to
change them combine them break them down
I'll show you an example of this so this
data right here column 0 column 1 column
2 they're all numerical column 2 is our
target we want to use column 0 and
column 1 we'll call them feature 0 and
feature one to predict feature to our
regression target which means we're
going to draw a line through a plot and
try to predict or model feature two when
we plot feature 0 against our target and
feature 1 against our target and we draw
the best line we can through those funny
fuzzy blobs it's a flat line there's no
slope to it at all
that's very unsatisfying what that means
is that if you tell me the value of
feature 1 or the value of feature 2 0
I'm gonna predict the same value of the
regression target every time the same
value for feature 2 it's a constant
guess which means it's not very
predictive sure enough there is a
measure of the goodness of that line as
a model as a description of the data
that's called the coefficient of
determination
when it's won the description is perfect
when it's zero the description is
worthless we're pretty close to zero
point oh one six so now I tell you that
feature zero is actually the departure
time in hours since midnight of a subway
train from the Central Square stop and
feature 1 is the arrival time in hours
since midnight of the same train at the
Kendall Square stop and that feature 2
is the maximum speed in km/h that the
Train reaches when going between the two
stops so we think about that and realize
departure time and arrival time are both
related to the speed and its peak speed
not average speed but there should still
be a relation there so they interact
alone they don't help us know what the
speed is but together they do well the
default way to handle interaction and
data is to multiply the data points
together so let's create a new data
point 0 times 1 we'll call it our new
feature and we plot it on the right-hand
side against our target our peak speed
and we draw a line through it and
unfortunately again we see it's a flat
line that's the best fit to that fuzzy
blob and sure enough our coefficient of
determination is still very close to 0
0.01 for just over 1% so we step back
again and we think freshman physics the
average speed is distance divided by
elapsed time which is arrival time -
departure time
- naught times so now we create a new
feature which is feature 1 - features
and this will be the difference of those
times it'll be the time in hours between
the two stops now when we create this
feature and plot it against the peak
speed we get a very different picture we
get a nice swoosh and sure enough the
best line that fits through that is very
predictive now if you tell me the
difference between feature 1 and feature
0 I can make a pretty good guess at what
the peak speed was between the two stops
and sure enough the coefficient of
determination of our model now is 0.88
pretty close to 1 so in order to get
this performance we had to take the
original features which were perfectly
accurate and full of good information
but we had to transform them so that the
algorithm could get the information that
it needed out of them there are lots of
different ways to do feature engineering
some of them are data specific they take
advantage of the fact that with certain
types of data like images interesting
information is stored in repeatable ways
similarly with text you can look at the
frequency that words occur and divide
that or scale that by the inverse
document frequency there are other
domain specific feature engineering
tricks depending on you're working in
whether you're working in economics or
agriculture or sociology different
things matter and sometimes you have to
take what you measure and do some tricks
with it before you get to the thing that
matters now you've probably heard about
deep learning it's been used sex
successfully with images and text and
audio to automatically learn all kinds
of features deep learning strength is
that it learns the patterns from the
data
and in fact it's outside the scope of
this talk but I'd like to use it for a
teaser there's another talk that I gave
recently that I'll share a link to at
the end of this talk on the fundamentals
of how deep learning works at the same
level no math no code just some of the
basic concepts now you've taken your
data you've asked a sharp question put
it in a table checked it it's
high-quality you've done your feature
engineering now you're ready to answer
your question what you're looking for is
whether that answer is clear whether it
lets you do what you want to do this is
where machine learning comes in it uses
statistics to look at patterns in the
past to predict patterns in the future
so of all the questions that you can ask
of your data it might surprise you that
there are really only five questions the
machining learning can answer or five
types of question we're gonna step
through each of them the first one is
how much or how many examples of this
are what will the temperature be on
Tuesday or what will my sales be next
quarter there are questions that ask for
a number the type of algorithms that
answer this are called regression
algorithms may involve fitting a line or
a curve or a surface to the data that
can be used as a simplified version a
cartoon version of the data and we'll
show how this works in just a few
minutes but how much or how many is a
very common question to ask of your data
another very common question is which
category if I get a picture is this
picture an image of a cat or a dog or if
I see a radar signature of all of the
aircraft in my library which
aircraft is probably causing this or I
read a news article of all the topics
that I've seen in the past which topic
or topics does this news article cover
this type of algorithm is called
classification and it's used to assign a
category or set of category to new
examples
the third question that you can ask of
your data is which groups which groups
does it naturally break down into this
is pretty common sometimes you just want
to take imagine someone gives you a bag
full of M&Ms and says hey break this
into groups that are similar doesn't
really matter how you do it
you'll probably start doing it by color
but you could also do it by weight or by
diameter or by sugar content there's
lots of different ways to do it but
however you do it it can be helpful so
common examples of this are which
shoppers have similar tastes in produce
if you've ever watched movies streaming
online you've probably had movies
recommended to you this is the result of
an algorithm that asks the question
which viewers liked the same kind of
movies and then it'll look and see which
movies your compatriots have seen that
you haven't seen yet and recommend them
to you another very popular question to
ask surprisingly popular is is this
weird you can have a long history of
observations and experience and it's
very useful to be able like to identify
when something weird happens raise a
flag and say hey I haven't seen this
before or at least not very often so for
instance if you drive a car that has
pressure sensors in the tire it's nice
to be able to answer the question is
this pressure reading unusual if you
have some kind of internet security
system
it's nice to be able to answer the
question is this internet message
typical your credit card company is
always asking the question is this
combination of purchases very different
from what this custom air is made in the
past when things are weird it doesn't
necessarily mean that something's wrong
but it can and when something's wrong
there's usually something weird about it
so it's a great place to focus your
detective efforts finally the fifth
question is which action should I take
so in the case where a machine
especially a robot needs to make a
decision it's a low consequence decision
and when the machine gets to make a lot
reinforcement learning is a way to do
this and to learn from your experience
so for instance an automatic temperature
control system in the building needs to
answer the question should I raise or
lower the temperature a little vacuum
cleaner in your house needs to answer
the question should I back you my living
room again or stay plugged into my
charging system and a self-driving car
may need to answer the question should I
break or accelerate in response to that
yellow light this is a little bit
different than the other questions but
I'm including it for completeness we
won't talk about it anymore today so
machine learning algorithms kind of
magical until you dig in we're gonna
pull the curtain back and show that it's
not really magic at all it's just a
little bit of patterned identification
so in this example I walk in to a
jewelry store I have an old ring that my
grandmother used to own and it has a
setting for a 1.35 carat diamond and I'd
like to fill that setting but first I
want to know how much is gonna cost so I
can save
so what I do is I go to the case and I
look at all of the diamonds and for each
one I know if the weight and I note the
price the first one I find is 1.01
carats and the price is seven thousand
three hundred sixty six dollars I note
it I move on and they fill up a list of
all of the diamonds in the case what I
have here is a data set there's two
columns in this case price is my target
that's what I want to predict there's
the question that I'm asking is how much
how much will this cost and then my
feature my other feature is karats
so in order to go to work here I first
draw a number line that represents the
weight in carats
looks like the range is about zero to
two so I make sure that it covers that
and draw some intermediate tick marks
and then I draw a perpendicular line to
represent price again I see that the
range is of almost a $20,000 so I put
that in with some intermediate tick
marks and I look at my very first data
point one point zero one carats and I I
ball vertical line from one point zero
one the carat line price 7366 dollars
III ball a horizontal line from 7366
where they meet and put a dot that data
point literally the dot represents the
first diamond on my list
I knew this again and again for every
diamond on the list and I get something
that looks like this
now this is just our data set it's
another representation we haven't done
anything funny to it we've just put it
in a different form now it's worth
noting on a tangent
about half the time when you're doing
data science you can stop right here if
I owned a business and I was asked what
size diamond should I choose in order to
make a ring as inexpensively as possible
from here it's obvious that price goes
down as weight goes down so the answer
is choose the lowest weight diamond you
possibly can
we're good at pulling out those type of
insights just using our eyes taking this
picture of the data and turning it into
an idea now the question that we're
asking is a little bit more subtle so we
need to take it to the next level if we
look at those dots and squint it looks
like a fat fuzzy line and it's not too
tough to eyeball you can take the marker
and draw a straight line right down the
middle of it now what we just did is
really significant we've created a model
which is kind of a fancy way of saying
that we took and made a simplified
version of our data now it is simplified
it is like a cartoon of our data you can
see any of those data points most of
them don't lie right on the line at all
that line is just an approximation it
kind of says what the model does and the
data scientists interpretation of this
is the line is the ideal it's what the
baseline price is per weight of a
diamond but because the real world is a
little bit gritty a little bit
unpredictable things happen you just
can't account for some of our gonna be
higher or some of our gonna be lower and
that's called noise or variance so your
data is always the model plus a little
bit of noise which is what we have here
so with a model that allows us to answer
our question this we drew it by hand but
it can also be the result of a machine
learning algorithm the question is how
much so we know the type is a regression
because we're using a line it's called a
linear regression so a linear regression
would use math to fit to these dots and
to generate something a whole lot like
this we did it with pen now that we have
a model we can answer our question how
much will a 1.35 carat diamond cost
there aren't any diamonds on our list
that are 1.3 5 carats so we have to
refer to our model we eyeball aligned
from 1.35 and right where it crosses our
model we eyeball a horizontal line and
it hits right at 8,000 boom there's the
answer the diamonds gonna cost us $8,000
now we look at those dots and we think
well most of those does don't lie right
on the line so is it gonna be a little
bit over a little bit under 8,000 or a
lot over or under and we can figure this
out too we go back to our dots and our
line and we draw a fat envelope around
the line that encompasses most of the
dots it doesn't have to capture all of
them this is called our confidence
interval this is our model extended out
to embrace most of what's there and
we're pretty confident the future data
points will also be in this envelope now
we can see where our 1.35 Caroline
crosses the top and the bottom of this
envelope and draw two more horizontal
lines over and this becomes a confidence
interval of our estimate so now we have
a more complete
you can say our 1.35 carat diamond will
cost about $8,000 but it'll almost
certainly be less than ten thousand two
hundred and greater than five thousand
eight hundred so I'd like to point out
what we just did let's create a linear
regression model to make a prediction
without using math or computer programs
now that's it's a pretty big deal you
should feel proud of yourself imagine
though if instead of just wait we had
several other characteristics of the
diamond like the color how close it is
to being white or the quality of the cut
or how many inclusions how many little
cracks or carbon granules are inside the
diamond a lot of other characteristics
those would translate into more columns
which would in turn translate into more
dimensions in our little plot because
our paper is two-dimensional like it's
hard to represent more than two
dimensions when we're drawing dots and
it gets really hard to draw lines and
planes in more than two dimensions this
is where math comes in and it can
automatically find the line or the plane
that fits as close as possible to the
middle of that slew of dots and then
imagine if you had instead of 15
diamonds you had 15 million then you
really want to have a computer involved
otherwise it's going to take you a very
long time to compute it but the basic
ideas are simple enough that you can do
it with pen and paper now in order to
get a good answer you need to have
enough data if you don't have enough
data what you get is kind of like this
you can see something but it's really
hard to know what it is and it's not
firm enough to base any decisions on so
you add data
you try again and then you end up with
just barely enough data and you know you
have just barely enough data because at
that point you can just barely make the
decision that you're trying to make
answer the question that you're trying
to answer so with this if you kind of
lean back and squint and say ah you know
what that looks like a canal that looks
like a gorgeous sunset with clouds in
the sky and those look like buildings
that is a beautiful place I want to go
there on vacation so I used the data and
I was able to interpret it to answer my
question do I want to go there on
vacation so that's how I knew I had
barely enough data now as you gather
more and more data the picture becomes
clearer and clearer and then eventually
you're able to look and make finer grain
decisions answer more questions now I
can say oh you know those three hotels
on the left bank the nearest one has
fascinating architectural features
that's where I want to stay in fact I
want the room on the third floor that's
the second from the right
I'm gonna see if I can get it so you
need to make sure you have at least
barely enough data more data is even
better so we've used our data to answer
our question but we're not done yet we
have to use the answer if a tree falls
in the forest and no one's around to
hear it it might make a sound but if you
don't use the beautiful model that you
built it definitely won't delight your
customers so ways to use the answer we
found you can make a web service this is
something that's exceptionally easy to
do with Azure machine learning which the
other talks today will cover in depth
you can make a decision do I want to go
there on vacation you can set a price
how much do I want to charge for this
you can take and publish your code on
github or in the Azure machine learning
gallery you can write a PDF showing your
results and share it around where you
can build a dashboard say with power bi
to show your results to potential
customers or to an employer there's lots
of ways to use it but you have to do
something with it a model or an analysis
all on its own
doesn't have any life now there are some
things to be aware of some gaps when
using your model nearly all machine
learning algorithms assume that the
world doesn't change if you gather your
data and the world changes in some
fundamental way then unfortunately your
data may all be invalid if I had
gathered information on air travel right
up until September 10th 2001 and then
tried to make predictions about
September 15th 2001 they would be
completely wrong because the world
changed fundamentally people's attitudes
changed and their plans change and
events changed on September 11th so you
need to make sure that your data is
relevant the world hasn't changed out
from under you
the second gap is related most machine
learning algorithms take lots of
examples to learn now if you're learning
something about say internet traffic and
you're collecting a billion packets in a
day then it won't take you long to
collect a nice sizable data set and to
be able to pull some conclusions out of
it but if you're studying something like
global climate change and one data point
is a single year then by the time you've
collected 10,000 data points the world
may have changed out from under you or
the results of your analysis may be no
longer
relevant because all of the people and
even all of the species that cared are
no longer around to benefit from the
answer
the third gap is that machine learning
can't tell what caused what so take this
example this is real data we have the
amount of cheese consumed in pounds per
person each year compared to the amount
of people the number of people who died
by getting tangled up in their bed
sheets and if you look at that plot you
can see there is a pretty close
relationship it would not be surprising
to see this plot in a news article with
the conclusion that cheese consumption
causes death by bed sheets similarly it
wouldn't be surprising to see it in the
next newspaper with the conclusion that
people getting tangled in their bed
sheets and dying causes their relatives
to eat more cheese either one is
plausible based on the data but the data
doesn't tell either of those stories
machine learning can't tell what's
caused what there's a third option which
is that these things are completely
unrelated causally but just random
chance
they showed a similar pattern this is
more than philosophical another example
that you might be familiar with you have
a case of the hiccups you're with your
friends and they start offering remedies
eat a spoonful of sugar drink three
glasses of water stand on your head and
you try these things in succession
eventually while you're doing one of
them your hiccups stop the friend will
say see mine worked if your other
friends are clever they'll say no no my
worked it just took a little while to
kick in in fact you can't tell that from
the experience the data just shows that
they're correlated not that they're
causally related now this example seems
trivial but it's very closely related to
our experience with economic recessions
there's a lot of different theories
about what causes them and what ends
them and usually successive leaders try
different theories in different
situations and whatever they happen to
be doing when the recession ends is
given credit but there's actually no way
to know for certain based on that data
alone whether it caused it or not
another example the name of the
conference some things are just a
coincidence
now these gaps are not showstoppers for
us we can close them with human insight
and judgment we're really good at making
reasonable guesses without having enough
information in fact we're so good at it
that we will usually make unreasonable
guesses even in the presence of enough
information but the upside of that the
survival value of that is that even when
we don't have enough information we'll
fill in the gaps and we'll build that
bridge it will make that intuitive leap
until the information catches up and can
close it for us and often it'll close it
exactly the way we bridged it but
occasionally it will surprise us and
close it a different way but the
important thing is that not having the
information doesn't stop us so we listen
to the data very carefully as far as it
goes and then go with our gut after that
so this is the complete cycle of using
data to answer a question when you're
done go back to the beginning get more
data ask another question and go through
it all again now I've put together some
resources related to each of these steps
please take some time and check it out
there's a link from this video and if
you go down in the comments and check it
out you'll be able to get to the slides
which in turn contain all of these links
if you have any questions or comments
please email me or reach out on Twitter
or on LinkedIn I would love to chat and
hear what you have to say thanks for
listening